i feel embarrassed that i don't know
this probably should but the i'm not a
robot
capture thing capture thing yeah so that
probably works in the same way like how
do you move your mouse maybe or how the
dynamics of the clicking totally
but how does that even work that well
then and why can't it be fake i need to
look into this because it's it's such a
trivial captcha it feels like should be
very crackable and yet a lot of
high security places use that yeah it's
really interesting it's another cat and
mouse game so i think they've yeah but
it's using a lot of similar signals like
mouse movements um keystrokes and then
obviously all the stuff that comes over
the the wire with your browser so like
what operating system what fonts you
know what headers are being sent over
and
um there's actually there's an old
website a camera was called it was kind
of like panoptix click or panopticon or
something but it basically was like a
proof of concept site that
um they would just show you all the data
that was kind of getting sent over with
your your request and like
say that there's only one person in the
world who has this exact set of data
it's you and so it's almost like
a work around a clever workaround to
track somebody
um make identify a unique person even if
like there wasn't a cookie involved or
something yeah this is a fascinating
world where you can't see anybody you're
in the dark
and yet you have a lot of signal you
have to figure out who's a real person
who's not who's a robot who's not
you